عشرات النجوم في العالم مثلوا انديتهم
ومنتخباتهم خلال 20 عاما الماضيه في خط
الهجوم برز العديد من الاسماء كان على
راسه ليونيل ميسي وكريستيانو رونالدو في
خط الوسط برزت حقبه تاريخيه في عالم الكره
تشكلت من سيرجيو بوسكيس واندرياس انيستا
وتشافي
شكلوا عماد الجيل الذهبي لبرشلونه
والمنتخب الاسباني لسنوات طويله فضلا عن
مودريتش وكروز ومسعود اوزيل في خط الدفاع
كانت هناك الكثير من الاسماء منها
وعلى صعيد حراسه المرمى كان الابرز جالوجي
بوفون ومنويل وكلاوتي برافو وفيكتور
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات